quand on s'intéresse un peu la trouille
en découle est un personnage finalement
beaucoup plus complexe que tu en as
l'air le dimanche après midi avec une
vision un peu comme des poupées russes
qui s'emboîtent
il fallait des poupées ce génie est le
premier personnage celui que tout le
monde connaît c'est le jacques martin
disons un peu comme sera peu démago faut
bien le dire un peu un peu populaire non
je sais pas je t'ai vu dimanche dernier
à la télévison port tudy disais dans mon
émission c'est le monde est à vous il
n'y a pas de gagnant il n'y a pas de
fernand et bien c'est les gens qui
disent on l'a gagnée heisbourg
parce que toute façon on est tous dans
le même bateau depuis vercingétorix
femme un peu non pas du tout je le pense
mais on n'est quand même pas tous dans
le même bateau il demandé on est
barcasse et d'autres qui sont en deuil
autre nom bruit parce que les gens parce
que la nature fait que les choses sont
inégales au départ mais je pense que
quand on a la chance d'avoir un gros
bateau il faut aider les petites barques
as je crois que s'il existe une
chevalerie de ce que j'appelle a entre
guillemets les intellectuels mes jambes
ça c'est de mettre son prêt d'honneur à
ne jamais se servir de ce que l'on sait
aux dépens de gens qui ne savent pas
alors le divan je ne fais pas de
démagogie j'aime ces gens ces gens font
partie intégrante de ma vie et je
faisais cette réflexion faupala dégagé
second texte à propos de chance on ne
chante jamais entendu qui m'inquiétait
ouais on a gagné on a gagné
ça veut dire qu'on a perdu
quand tu vas à la concorde étudient dans
dans france soir que tu as pris le
risque que les situations soient soit
menacé tu sais déjà qu'avec l'audimat ce
qui fait sur la deux le dimanche après
midi sa situation n'est pas menacé
j'en ai vu d'autres danièle gilbert
daniel gilbert vrai faux c'est une très
belle émission je lui avais laissé ses
mots libye / mardi elle faisait 28 noms
but j'ai quand même une certaine dame
utile de la télé ça fait 35 ans enfin et
c'est pas moi qui suis inquiet parce que
moi personnellement ça ne m'inquiète pas
trop tu vois mais ce sens mes camarades
autour de moi puis on vote et tu penses
que tu as pris un ris maintenant la
concorde
oui un certain si on est vraiment un
professionnel en travaillant sur oise de
l'état où les gens sales bien qu'en
prenant position autour de pouvoir
généralement ça se paye mais je dis pas
je te dis pas que le on va me virer nous
atterrissons divergent mais il est si on
peut le faire chez elle une candidate
qui a fait zéro oui alors quand elle a
un candidat à café 0 alors tu dis on va
toutes façons moi aussi quand je t'ai
l'école j'avais toujours zéro et c'est
vrai
et puis c'est pas grave d'avoir zéro
alors on sait jamais si tu as eu le
certificat d'études seulement le
baccalauréat ce s'arrêter aux études ça
officiellement ça c'est un oui j'ai une
scientifique allaient d'une province
et puis c'est bien bien bien bien plus
tard où j'ai commencé mes études j'ai
recommencé des études mais est-ce que ça
c'est pas tout ça de la provocation un
peu contre les intellos et la gauche
caviar que tu déteste qu'on est au sol -
midi caste et si à l'occasion d'un
nouveau mai 68 qui avait quelque chose
j'irai placer quelques grenades ni à
l'observateur oui ce sont des ennemis de
castres ça fait 30 ans que ces gens-là
chie sur ce que je fais sur mes livres
sur mes films sur les émissions de télé
alors pendant une trentaine d'années
j'en ai eu peur on voit donc
oui je vous remercie de m'avoir dit dans
le journal de tintin en foire et ouais
voilà même jour disait bonjour le soir
quand j'ai rencontré chez castel est ce
que la gauche va chez castel et puis un
certain mois on évolue tu vois j'ai
attrapé mes 55 ans et pas mal d'autres
choses aussi et je me suis dit que
j'étais complètement cours de pactiser
avec mes ennemis donc maintenant tu la
rendre payante à doha il faut savoir que
maintenant je vais tirer leur tienne
étiré yeux parce que la gauche que je
déteste c'est pas bien entendu les
communes y jouent tous les gens qui sont
vraiment du peuple c'est les fossés loin
les petits [ __ ]
la gauche est celui dans lequel a
enchaîné disent que oui nation qui
aiguille je suis à comique pour ne s'est
vendu analphabètes que je suis
représentant de commerce comme si dire
de quelqu'un c'est un représentant de
commerce étaient une injure c'est
s'amincissent mme tuer des représentants
de commerce de rodez bus entre jeu tout
fait moi ouais mais ce que je veux dire
c'est que quelque part c'est fini je ne
sais plus de concessions mais il faut
qu'il le sache je suis dit pour
quelqu'un qui n'est pas franc maçon et
qui fait pas partie du racing je me suis
pas mal des mers desai le sata oui oui
la revanche qua non j'ai pas de revanche
est plus dans japan toi dans mon bon je
vais maquette n'est pas ici quand on a
55 ans mathématiquement la moelle tort
moins de temps à passer sur cette terre
on en a déjà
oui ça c'est sûr a fait le plus gros bon
on a fait le plus gros seins sur le dim
10 55 par deux ça ferait sans disque on
n'y arrive pas c'est sûr donc qu'il
reste moins de temps a passé et comme je
suis ainsi baril ce que j'aime le
bonheur que j'aime vivre que j'aime
vit passionnément je ne vais plus
m'emmerder est beaucoup plus jeune que
les autres je suis arrivé un état
raisonnable je les histoires de la terre
ne me concerne pas tellement parce que
le mieux même si je commets commettait
un meurtre aujourd'hui le minimum dont
je courais copé serait inférieur au
temps qui me reste donc je n'en ai rien
à [ __ ] qui tu déteste le plus à gauche
caviar le person personne je trouve
pénible certaines attitudes par exemple
se trouve très très pénibles l'attitude
de guy bedos la semaine dernière et si
j'étais françois mitterrand je
convoquerai billy bedos entendue disant
arrêtez vous fait du tort une fatale des
voix oui parce que tu vois dans
l'émission de ce charmant copains il a
été faire autrement notre charmant comme
dechavanne dechavanne qui démarre son
émission qui est là tout timide parce
qu'on est timide les 15 premières années
on fait la télévision
cissé il faut quinze ans pour cesser dès
midi et voilà que 10 fait du terrorisme
et lui dit les choses méchantes qui m'a
frappé si vous continuez cette émission
je verrai vous faites là en france est
vrai que cette année y apprend t-on
c'est le doute qui habite dechavanne ce
garçon timide tellement timide qui parle
vite par peur d'avoir un trou est un
charmant garçon lui a dit je fais la
première est sans doute la dernière
oui bon tu vois est ce que tu crois eu
de la part d'un mec qui à bientôt 60 ans
et la bouteille est une île à 60 en plus
sa moumoute 70 alors est ce que tu crois
que c'est bien qu'avec de 60 ans rich
hume à ce que ces chers les secteurs et
véloce viennent faire du terrorisme
intellectuel au pad dechavanne qui
commence alors que de chavanette à
charmant garçon est ce que c'est bien
d'abord de guy bedos doter le pain du
match que igor qui est un avis et qui
fait qu'inventer les parfums pour
attirer non parce qu'on a le droit
quand on a une place de tir elle se
gagne par les autres non
disons que je trouve cette attitude
négative mais je ne déteste pas non
c'est pas de sa faute c'est un enfant
valeureux prolongée taylor ya un autre
martin senmartin écorché c'est martin
qui a souffert quand il était petit oui
là j'ai souffert mais tout le monde a
souffert j'ai souffert jusqu'à je sais
j'ai souffert j'ai souffert mais tout le
monde c'est vrai que ton père est revenu
de la guerre de 14 et le colis qu'à
cause de ce qu'ils avaient vu prendre la
guerre oui mon père a fait la guerre de
14 18 il avait 20 verges en 14 et
il était officier il a été officier au
front et évidemment il a vu pour pas
voir ce qu'il faisait et il est resté il
est bord de ça on en a mis dans un
collège personnes franck lucas devant
toi ma mère travaille et enfin c'est
toute une histoire ça c'est très intime
sa journée en parler complètement j'ai
refusé 20 fois de raconter ma vie
par contre je veux bien raconter mon
voyage ce que je veux bien raconté c'est
l'histoire d'un garçon qui est parti à
15 ans chez lui même bien avant qui est
parti à 6 ans de chez lui et a rencontré
tout ce que j'ai rencontrés car j'ai
rencontré des gens extraordinaires comme
un truc fou c'est face on le sait même
s'il n'a jamais raconté c'est qu'un un
jour tu as fait une fugue et personne
personne n'a cherché
vous voyez aussi mais ça n'est pas très
important mais ce que j'ai ramené de ce
que j'ai vu c'est viable
j'ai quand même connu ma l'appart j'ai
connu jouant dont je connaissais je n'ai
j'ai connu des tas de gens des tas de
choses j'ai fait le tour du monde
plusieurs fois parce que je suis curieux
tout ça c'est intéressant raconte et
c'est ce que je vais raconter enfin
liste la comédie musicale que je qu'on
va donner au théâtre marigny à partir du
22 septembre
ça s'appelle la lune avec les dents et
c'est l'histoire d'un mec qui s'appelle
martin dupont ou durand qui est né en
1933 et il monte il sait ça y est c'est
ce que j'ai croisés
ma route c'est ça et c'est drôle mais
est ce que tu as fait tes embringué
finalement dans la télé comme ça parce
que si tu avais cette année six enfants
à nourrir trois zones non pas du tout
j'ai tort bringuy parle at il dans
l'interview parce que j'avais eu un
chagrin d'amour avec le cinéma
oui comme mon film est sorti quand elle
avait tourné à nice je crois qu'il y
avait beaucoup de choses dedans beaucoup
de choses formidables et bien avant la
lettre
et puis les intellectuels de gauche on
tirait dans le film on partage on dirait
dans à bout portant et il a bien fallu
payer le film alors je suis entré à la
télé et quant à quitter midi magazine la
première fois tu as dit par goût de la
sécurité ou par lâcheté je pourrais
rester là et puis finalement si je
restais là j'y serais encore dans 30 ans
oui bien sûr est ce que finalement c'est
pas ce qui t'es arrivé je suis passé
trente ans ça fait dix ans que je suis
en témoin en plus qu'est-ce que je me
marre ouais parce que je suis très loin
de la maison mère
j'ai un théâtre 41 vite wagram j'ai la
même équipe petite équipe courte pige à
fait de l'athénée et on est très très
très très très très très très loin des
discussions de couloir ou du côté et
comme la maison en tête de la confiance
en moi je suis un petit peu gouverneur
général mais j'en vois de temps en temps
quelqu'un cherchait des troubles mais où
des enveloppes à la maison mère à la
maison mère mais en dehors de ça le
théâtre de l' empire on fait tout
nous-mêmes et les listes regrette pas de
l'avoir écrit parce que tu en as fait un
lanestérien forte chaleur
je suis en train de préparer plus jolie
sûr que maintenant finalement au bout de
quelques années tu as fini par admettre
comme take that a pu ces velléités que
tout le monde a c'est à dire de façon je
vais évoluer français qui pourrait faire
je suis passé au sol supérieure puis il
ya des taux d'occupation qui vous
tombent au bout de au bout de six
enfants commencent à mieux comprendre la
famille au but 2-2 mariage on saisit
mieux les femmes et aubry
de 25 ans de spectacle on est en venu
pas mal de vanité sur le show business
ont la fragilité nos professions et puis
moi la seule chose qui m'intéresse c'est
de bien vivre la minute qui m'est donnée
comme à présent de bien vivre celle
d'après de bien vivre demain et le reste
je m'en fous ça n'a aucune espèce
d'importance puisque je considère que
nous sommes de passage c'est la
psychanalyse qui t'a aidé beaucoup mais
c'est très loin la psychanalyse remonte
à quinze c'est pour débarrasser du
catholicisme que tu as pris date pas du
tout je suis tu je suis un croyant
extraordinaire je crois la résurrection
je crois fortement lorsque tu choisis
freud et mon dieu mais dieu mais en
réalité il ya qu'à dieu
il ya un dieu mais on l'appelle dicks
pour arranger tout le monde
on n'a pas affaire de racisme justement
c'est ça mais je crois à la résurrection
tu vois il ya un écrivain américain qui
s'appelle richard bach qui a écrit une
phrase définitive sur lequel tous les
êtres humains devraient méditer
il faut bien écouter ça ce que la
chenille appelle la fin du monde
lemaitre lui l'appelle le papillon et je
pense exactement ce à quoi nous nous
sommes des chenilles mais quelque part
sans se place sur un autre degré moi je
sais qu'on ressuscite en papillon et
j'en ai même la preuve